こんにちははじめ社長です皆さんが声
自分の声気にしたことありますでしょうか人を形成するものは様々なものがあります声
髪型顔の形 ik あまざまな要素があってはじめてその人というものが私は人の体の
中で重要なパートして声がとても重要だと
思いますか声で結構イメージとかって変わるんですよもう声優さんとか声でご飯を食べ
ている人もいるぐらいやー声っていうのは人の中でも大事なものなんですけどもう
ちょっと今回はあの僕いつもこんなに硬くもなく低くはなく何とも言えない声を出すん
ですけども
こんな僕がもし声が変わるとどんな感じになるのかってちょっと純正に思いました何と
もこの動画を見てんつ
床への大事さとかがわかればいいなと思ってるんでちょっと今日は何気ない普段の生活
をしてみたんですけども僕の声だけをちょっととビックさんに今回やってもらいまして
とビックさんからなく声の素材もらったんでそれを基にちょっとどんどん作ってみたの
で今日の動画で僕の声がとみっきさんだったらどんな感じになるのかっていうの
ちょっと皆さんに聴いてもらいたいと思います人の子
カーライルどれくらい変化するの音はどうぞよね
うわぁ
う今日も疲れたなぁ
よいしょさーてインターネットでも通過
4歳と燃えるファイト大
tm
んあその前によるは変えるレーザー今何か入ってるかな
たぁさん南関3段々だろグランランタンそんなあああああっ
ハッカーんぐっ
ゴクゴクゴクウニャー
うーんの差じゃねぇ
おそろっ
潤アークマ英俊
12:00ぶん殴る練習をしよう
うや知恵
いいした
ます
合わせたん3段々炭酸楽なんだだんだん炭酸がみたいな感じです
me
続つが右端散乱断炭酸何なんだななんだんたんさんなんです
完璧です張らせる
戻ります
わからず打撲殺害しています
れたなぁ
よいしょ
さてサイトもエロバイト
第さーん
入ってくださった
には幸庵
うん